hey 42 here the humble caterpillar is
one of the most mind shatteringly
incredulous creatures on planet earth
there's so much more to this chubby worm
than meets the eye if there was a prize
for the animal most likely to be a
Pokemon then this suave fella would take
gold because it evolves not once but
twice first from a larva to a
caterpillar then finally into a
beautiful butterfly actually it's so
alike a pokemon it already is one but
how does a living organic thind
metamorphosize so consistently and so
perfectly into a completely different
creature of an entirely different shape
and sally's you may be either grossed
out when I tell you this or totally
amazed
but inside the chrysalis the caterpillar
completely liquid Isis turning into a
mush of gooey proteins and fibers and it
slowly reforms into a butterfly over ten
days we'll talk more about metamorphosis
later but first let's start from the
beginning of this incredible insects
life cycle because this amazing insect
has so many secrets of its sleeve or
wings that you're not going to want to
miss any of it
a female butterfly will first find a
nice-looking tree and lay its tiny eggs
on the underside of the tree or plants
leaves each egg contains a tiny tiny
caterpillar larva but the mother is
extremely picky about which plant gets
to play host to her ex each different
species of butterfly uses a different
species of plant to lay their eggs on
and only that plant this is all made a
thousand times more complicated when you
consider that there are over 20 thousand
species of butterfly in the world the
egg is the size of a pinhead and the
mother will lay 500 eggs at a time it
then takes four days for the egg to
hatch by this point the larva is freakin
starving so it eats its way out of its
own egg then it eats the rest of the
eggshell as well it also eats the entire
leaf it's on and they will probably have
a good going to leave
next to it as well this first meal is
very dangerous because the various
sticky residues found inside some
species of leaves can cause to
caterpillar larvas month to go more many
caterpillars will die from this if it
does survive this great feast then all
this sustenance gives the greedy little
fella energy to grow into several times
its size it will then take a break to
shed its first layer of skin the
caterpillar will then spend the next
week eating leaves and growing into a
full sized caterpillar once fully grown
this ravenous tyrant can eat a full leaf
and under an hour
once the caterpillar has gotten all nice
and fat it prepares for the big change
it finds a nice quiet spot underneath a
branch and spins itself a silk button to
attach yourself to the underside of the
branch other species get even fancier
and spin a fine silk harness that they
sit inside and now begins the magic
trick it's commonly thought that the
caterpillar now makes its chrysalis also
known as a pupa but not a cocoon not
something else but it doesn't make it it
in fact grows this hardened shell
underneath its top layer of skin in the
week leading up to his metamorphosis so
when the time comes all it has to do is
shed its top layer of skin and its
protective pupa is all ready for the
transformation to begin but the
caterpillar has another sneaky magic
trick up its sleeve to disguise itself
from predators the pupa will change its
color to exactly match that of whatever
is behind it and so the transformation
begins taking roughly two weeks to turn
from a furry slot into a beautiful wings
insect but if you were able to see
inside the pupa whilst this is taking
place you might be rather horrified the
transformation beginning with the
caterpillar releasing digestive enzymes
to eat itself alive effectively turning
itself into a suit
yuck if you were to cut open a peeper at
the right time during metamorphosis I GU
would booze out but this magic goo
contains everything needed to create a
butterfly and that is rather incredible
but not every cell liquefies certain
groups of highly organized cells remain
as solids within the zoo over the course
of two weeks this caterpillar curry
slowly turns into a butterfly broth and
then into an actual butterfly all from a
gooey liquid it's such an incredible
phenomenon that scientists still hunt
quite sure how this liquid organizes
itself into a butterfly what's so
amazing about all of this is that
everything about the creature changes
during a transformation its shape its
tastes how it eats how it moves and how
it senses yet the butterfly is still
able to remember its life as a
caterpillar you would think that your
brain being turned into a soup then
reshaped into a completely new braid
would erase all of your memories but a
recent study showed that water flies
were able to remember the solution to a
puzzle that they were taught how to
solve when they were a caterpillar
meaning some of the synaptic connections
in the caterpillars brain must survive
the super vacation making the humble
caterpillar one of the true wonders of
the natural world thanks for watching
some photos can tell rich detailed
stories always inspire a thousand
questions but there's an even more
dangerous drug a substance so terrifying
that it would have bought labor boat
back down to earth